die top fünf fakten über polen und die
besten tipps oder wie man heute sagt
live hacks gegen pollen rund zwölf
millionen menschen in deutschland haben
ihre eigenen einschätzung nach probleme
damit warum es derzeit so schlimm ist
und effektive tipps gegen die laster der
allergie jetzt bei pixum
los geht's mit dem ersten akt
beziehungsweise erst mal eine these auf
der 5 wenn es regnet fliegen keine
pollen das ist allerdings eher ein
mythos als ein fakt denn eigentlich ist
die aussage totaler quatsch
wenn es regnet werden zwar die pollen
von bäumen oder gräsern abgespült landen
aber nicht direkt auf dem boden
erst werden die pollen etwas
aufgewirbelt und bis dann alles mal
durch die tropfen am boden gelandet ist
dauert es oft bis zu einer halben stunde
zudem gibt es ja auch sporen von
schimmelpilzen auf die man allergisch
reagieren kann und die können nur
produziert werden wenn es kühl und
feucht ist regen ist also nicht direkt
ein schutz gegen polen und aus eigener
erfahrung kann ich nur sagen das
gegenteil kann der fall sein meinen
ersten asthma anfall hatte ich an einem
richtig regnerischen tag die hohe
luftfeuchtigkeit im zusammenhang mit
starken pollenflug hat dazu geführt dass
ich kaum noch luft bekam
für einen weg von etwa fünf metern habe
ich an diesem tag rund zehn minuten
gebraucht weil ich einfach kaum noch
atmen konnte back 4
neben den bekannten symptomen wie eine
verstopfte nase ein gereizter hals oder
tränende augen gibt es auch noch ganz
andere auswirkungen
wer unter einer extremen pollenallergie
leidet ist nämlich oft auch anfällig für
konzentrations oder schlafstörungen
das risiko für allergiker an einer
depression zu erkranken kann auch höher
sein
letzteres tritt je nach verfassung des
betroffenen aber meistens nur im zuge
einer ganzjährigen pollenallergie oder
in kombination mit anderen
unverträglichkeiten auf und auf platz 3
der pollen fakten es hängt schon früh an
die wenigsten verbinden pollen mit dem
winter den sollten einige allergiker
allerdings bedenken haselnuss pollen
oder auch erlenpollen können schon im
winter zur plage werden bei mir fängt
das niesen deswegen auch schon im januar
an im sommer sind dann die gräser die
kräuter und auch die schimmelpilze aktiv
im aktuellen monat also im mai haben
bäume wie die pappel weide birke oder
auch die eiche die oberhand
besonders fies dieses jahr ist dass die
bürger alle zwei jahre einen extremen
schub erfährt und besonders viele pollen
abgibt und ja dieses jahr war es mal
wieder so weit bei mir war es also
richtig heftig aber gott sei dank habe
ich vor einigen jahren eine
hyposensibilisierung gemacht
und mir drei jahre lang jeden winter die
stoffe gegen die ich allergisch bin mit
steigender dosis wochenlang spritzen
lassen
im vierten jahr habe ich deutlich
weniger allergisch reagiert mein asthma
ist seitdem weitgehend weg eine allergie
kommt selten allein und damit zum fakt
auf der zwei wer unter einer
pollenallergie leidet hat auch oft mit
anderen allergien probleme so was nennt
man dann kreuzallergie das immunsystem
der betroffenen erkennt bei anderen
stoffen ähnliche epitope das sind
strukturen an proteinen und dann
reagiert es darauf wir auf den
eigentlichen allergieauslösenden stoff
wer zum beispiel gegen die birkenpollen
allergisch ist verträgt auch häufig
keine pflaumen aprikosen kirschen
pfirsiche äpfel birnen kiwis avocados
und noch einige andere lebensmittel
seitdem gegen gräser allergisch könntet
ihr auch parallel mit einer erdnuss
sellerie oder auch kartoffel allergie zu
tun haben wenn ihr also heuschnupfen
habt und bemerkt dass ihr bei manchen
lebensmitteln ähnliche symptome zeigt
dann lasst euch doch mal durchchecken
und macht eine hyposensibilisierung wenn
die allergie zu heftig ist am besten
noch bevor ihr allergisches asthma wie
ich bekommt und der letzte fakt vor den
tipps top verkauf der einst viel ist
viel eher mit vielen geschwistern
aufgewachsen seid habt ihr glück gehabt
nicht nur weil er so gut wie immer
jemanden zum spielen hatte sondern auch
weil allergien darauf wenig chancen
haben bei euch zu landen der regel und
zugleich konstante austausch von keimen
und allergien zwischen so vielen kindern
würde wissenschaftlern zufolge dafür
sorgen dass die abwehrkräfte langsam
aber eben auch konstant gefordert werden
folge ein starkes und vielseitig
ausgebildetes immunsystem das ist
übrigens auch der grund warum es immer
mehr allergiker gibt die kinderzimmer
werden immer hygienischer kinder spielen
kaum noch draußen und das immunsystem
wird höchstens noch von milch mix
getränken gestärkt also die konsequenz
babys ist mehr dreck und das ist kein
witz
babys sollten mehr dreck essen um ihr
immunsystem zu stärken durch die
bakterielle giftstoffe im dreck wird
nämlich die bildung von th1 helferzellen
stimuliert damit zirkulieren weniger th2
helfer zellen im blut und die sind für
allergische reaktionen zuständig
und jetzt kommen wir zu den tipps die
euch hoffentlich ein wenig besser durch
die pollen zeit kommen lassen auf der 5
der top tipps oder wie man heute sagt
live acts in der pollenflugzeit ist
draußen seien oft sehr unangenehm wenn
er aber dennoch an die frische luft voll
dann geht am besten in den wald die
bäume halten viele pollen fern auf der 4
und kommt hier von draußen nach hause
zieht euch nur darum wo ihr euch nicht
lange aufhalten günstige orte flur oder
keller ungünstige orte schlafzimmer oder
wohnzimmer und auf der 3 auch wenn er
euch bettfertig macht achtet darauf euch
nicht im schlafzimmer selbst umzuziehen
und auf der 2 bevor sie ins bett geht
haare waschen denn wo sich pollen
richtig fies verstecken das sind die
haare wenn sich der blütenstaub dann
nachts in richtung nase und augen bewegt
ist das denkbar ungünstig und die einst
einfach und wirkungsvoll weil er auf
viel zeit im auto verbringt es gibt
spezielle pollenfilter für
lüftungsanlagen also startet eure
lüftung im auto damit aus und lasst sie
wie möglich regelmäßig von jemandem
reinigen der nicht gerade selbst eine
pollenallergie hat wie geht es euch im
moment mit der polin ag seit er
verschont geblieben oder nicht und wenn
nicht könnt ihr uns allen noch ein paar
tipps in die kommentare schreiben ich
würde mich über zahlreiche ratschläge
und tipps und natürlich live acts freuen
wenn euch die tipps und das video
gefallen hat dann bitte einen daumen
nach oben
und natürlich gerne wir freuen uns über
jedes kostenlose abo ja und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran